Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 26. Now we're actually going to
look at day trading or short-term trading
around short-term volatility. Up to this
point, what we identified right at the
beginning of the video series, which is
why we've been covering up to this point
only portfolios.
What we saw right at the beginning of the
video series was that 80% of the time in
the stock market, volatility to trade on a
short-term basis just isn't really there.
And we looked at day trading as an
example, and that really did show us that
on a normal day, a one standard deviation
day, 80% of the time, volatility on a day
trading basis, on a daily basis,
the odds really don't work in terms of
making money over one day. And when we
looked at the implied volatility, so the
implied volatility, the VIX, the
volatility index of major stock markets,
and in particular, we looked at the S&P
500, the world's largest stock market,
what we realized was that this volatility
index agreed with the historical
volatility as well.
And of course it should, they should
match. And the VIX, the volatility index
of the S&P 500 shows that 80% of the time,
the VIX is below an annualized 25%, which
when you back it out, means on a daily
basis, the volatility of the S&P 500 just
isn't there for any traders to make money
short-term.
So 80% of the time, we realize that
essentially we have to be portfolio
managers, and then we have to transition
from being portfolio managers to
short-term traders when volatility
increases, but we also have to transition
back from being short-term traders to
portfolio managers when volatility is
reduced.
So essentially we're going back to this
idea that as a trader, your job really is
that you're a slave to volatility. So 80%
of the time we're portfolio managers,
that's why we've been concentrating on it
so much.
So that's the first reason why we're
leaving day trading to this point. The
second reason we're leaving day trading to
this point is because a lot of the
techniques and a lot of the processes that
we've used in portfolio management are
actually used in day trading as well.
So now that we know these, we can now
apply them to a day trading scenario. And
what we're really going to look at is the
hunt for volatility on a short-term basis.
So now that we understand volatility, we
know how to hunt for it.
Secondly, we look at the ATR, so the
average true range of a stock or an asset
on a daily basis. The ATR, we pull that up
before we go and day trade. And why we
pull that up is because we want to manage
our expectations and set stops and targets
accordingly.
So first of all, identifying volatility.
Secondly, setting expectations, stops and
targets to make sure that our expectations
are realistic. A lot of retail traders
don't really have the correct expectations
when they go into day trading.
The third thing, we've got a download,
which is available in the download
section, which actually outlines all of
the best practices that you should really
have.
As somebody who's taking a day trading
approach. So those three things we're
going to look at. Let's go over to the
presentation. The presentation this time
is actually going to just be on the
computer.
So we're going to run through the slides
on the computer and I'll see you back at
the end of this video for a summary of day
trading.
Okay, so welcome back to the computer
screen. We're going to have a look now at
the basics of day trading. And some of the
principles here and quite a few of the
concepts you will have seen in previous
videos in the series.
And also applied to portfolio management.
But now our time horizon has significantly
reduced. So instead of having a one to
three month time horizon, we're now
looking at having a time horizon of one
day or maybe just a few days.
So our time horizon significantly
decreased. However, a lot of the
principles and concepts that you've seen
so far throughout the video series apply.
Just because we've changed our time
horizon doesn't mean we change our general
approach to analyzing assets and trading
those assets.
So we just have to use our resources in a
smarter way over the time horizon we're
looking at. So in this presentation, we're
going to do this on the computer screen
instead of going over to the stage,
because it's quite important to get the
principles and concepts here. So I thought
it'd be better to do this on the screen.
And because day trading can be quite
volatile and quite difficult to make money
with. We've included a best practices
guide in the download section. And the
best practices guide really just covers
all of the main approaches that you should
really be taking.
So across mental preparation, your general
preparation, your general preparation,
your preparation in terms of analyzing the
overall market, and what you should be
doing when you're really approaching day
trading as an exercise.
And you should have to do this. And you
should review this. And, you know, when
you're thinking of day trading, and you
believe you're in the position to do so,
you should review this just very quickly.
And, you know, it's only a couple of
pages. And it's, it shouldn't take you too
long to, to cover those principles and
concepts in terms of the approach.
And it's well worth doing because it will
save you a lot of money. It will save you
a lot of money and potentially make you a
lot of money if you keep going back to
this and reviewing your day trading.
So that's in the download section, the
best practices guide, make sure you
download that and read it.
What we're going to do now is go through
this presentation slide by slide.
The first thing we're going to look at is
really the importance of volatility. So
we've seen the concepts of volatility in
earlier videos, we're going to review
those just to make sure that we've got the
right approach here.
Then we're going to be looking at how we
use the Kelly criterion, how you monitor
your discipline and track record, and have
self-awareness as a trader within day
trading.
We're also going to have a look at how
news flow affects you as a day trader, and
how you connect the dots and hunt for
volatility, and also how you know your
asset.
And really, knowing your asset is knowing
the volatility and the opportunities in
the asset.
So let's kick this off. And we're looking
here at the S&P 500 volatility index from
1993 to 2013.
And you can see over the last 20 years,
you know, how low the average level of the
volatility index really is.
You're looking really at a volatility
index of between 15 and 20 as the average,
which when you back this out into a day
trading situation,
we've already seen that this implies that
80% of the time we have to be portfolio
managers simply because when you look at
the volatility on a daily basis,
what occurs 80% of these times is that you
get a move in the S&P 500, which is within
plus or minus half a percent.
And on a probability adjusted basis,
you're basically looking at a gross move
per day of plus or minus 35 or 33 basis
points.
So 0.35 or minus 0.33.
And when you actually think about trading
and then having to pay to trade as well,
that theoretical exercise that we did
right at the beginning of the video series
where we said, OK, if we paid a round trip
of 35 basis points in and out,
that just means if we're day trading the
average stock in the S&P 500, it just
means that we're going to be wiped out in
all situations on a normal day,
which means basically we can't make money.
So we're not saying day trading is bad
here.
All we're saying is that the market tells
us that we can't do it 80% of the time,
but 20% of the time we can do.
So when we look at portfolio risk, you
know, if we assume that 80% of the time
we're going to be portfolio managers and
this is what professional traders are.
80% of the time they are portfolio
managers. Why? Because they're slaves to
volatility.
The volatility in the market tells them
the opportunities over any given time
horizon.
And we looked at this concept right at the
beginning of the video series where we
made that statement that volatility is a
trader's best friend and a portfolio
manager's worst enemy.
And that the VIX is actually not a fear
index of the market going down, but
actually a fear of volatility itself.
So what this implies is that if the
volatility index moves, whatever it moves
by, if we assume that the whole world is
in portfolio management,
then it means the risk of every portfolio
manager has gone up by that percentage.
So first things first, if the VIX goes up
by 25%, it literally just means that the
portfolio risk of the entire world has
gone up by 25%.
So remember this example where we were
running the $1 million portfolio, the
theoretical $1 million portfolio.
And you can go back and review this right
at the beginning.
When the VIX doubles, that $1 million
gross exposure yesterday, whether we like
it or not, becomes $2 million,
because the P&L move from that portfolio
doubles in size.
So all that happens is, is that portfolio
managers have taken more risk without
actually doing anything.
Therefore, they're forced to come into the
market and reduce their exposure.
So when you see the VIX moving up sharply
by a big amount.
So let's say the VIX is even as low as
10%, which is extremely low on the S&P 500
volatility index.
If the VIX is 10 and it jumps to 12 and a
half, it's up 25%.
And if it's, if it jumps from 10 to 15,
it's up 50%.
And what you'll find is, is that if the
VIX has spent a very long time at low
levels,
what you will get is a lot of complacency
in the market because portfolio managers
have been building portfolios for a long
time with the VIX at that level.
And people start to feel comfortable that
the VIX is going to stay low for a very
long time.
And then when, when, when something
happens in the world and it jumps
suddenly, well, all of a sudden the
world's portfolio risk goes up by that
percentage amount.
And the converse is true.
The converse is true.
So the opposite is true as well.
When the VIX, you know, drops by from say
25 to 12 and a half.
Well, the VIX is down 50%, which means
portfolio risk is down 50%.
And in this example here, we're saying
it's down 25%.
This just means that the portfolio risk of
the world has gone down by 20%.
So small typo here, just ignore that.
It actually just means that it's gone down
by 25%.
So what does this mean?
Well, when we're slaves to volatility as
professional traders, the way we have to
approach this is that we have to be
portfolio managers roughly 80% of the time
with the knowledge that we can't really
trade on a short-term basis because the
market doesn't really allow us to.
However, 20% of the time throughout
history, what's happened?
Well, we've been given opportunities to do
that.
So we transition from being portfolio
managers to day traders or short-term
traders when we're given the opportunity
to do so.
And we transition back when we're not
given the opportunity to do so and we
build portfolios.
So this is why when you see the VIX moving
in a big way, usually you see the market
move in a big way up or down because
market participants are either de-risking
or re-risking.
So they're either taking off portfolios or
putting them back on.
So it's pretty obvious what we need to do.
We want to be de-risking before them and
we want to be transitioning.
Because what happens is when people
de-risk, they create short-term trading
opportunities in the market.
And we have to have cash or margin
available to take advantage of these
opportunities.
If we're fully invested in our portfolio,
then we can't take advantage of them.
So we want to try and be ahead of the
game.
And the way we should probably look at it
is this traffic light system where if
we're told that we can't day trade because
we have a very low VIX and usually this is
below 25% on the annualized volatility of
the VIX.
And, you know, there's no rules here, you
know, you might want to put a limit on it
of 20% or even 15%, but usually 80% of the
time it's below 25% annualized volatility
on the S&P 500 volatility index.
So when it's below that level and it's
dropped 25%, what's happened?
Well, it means that the portfolio risk of
the world is dropping.
So what you get paid to be a portfolio
manager is now better.
You're becoming the opportunities to get
paid as a portfolio manager are
increasing.
So we want to be transitioning into being
portfolio managers at these times.
Then, right on the other side, let's say,
for example, the VIX jumps 25% or more
from wherever the level is that it's been
at for a while.
That just means that the risk of the world
has gone up by 25%.
So the global risk of portfolio management
is up by 25%, which means the world is now
being paid less to be portfolio managers.
Whether they like it or not, their risk is
going up by this amount.
So their P&L swings, the volatility of
their P&L swings, is going up by this
amount.
And they may be forced to de-risk.
So we want to be predicting this and we
want to be making sure that we do
something about it.
So this is why we transition.
So these are all back of the envelope
numbers.
You can't, again, go down to the local
bookstore or go onto Amazon.com and buy a
book which says you should do this in all
situations when trading volatility or
transitioning.
But when we get the green light to do so,
you should probably be thinking of doing
something.
Because you don't want the opposite to
happen.
The opposite is you're fully invested as a
portfolio manager.
You do nothing.
And then you're the rabbit in the
headlights.
And then you have to trade out of your
portfolio when volatility has already
rallied.
And it's now on its highs because all
you're going to do there is provide
liquidity for all the day traders to make
money out of you.
So we want to be doing something when we
see the VIX rallying 25% or more.
And this is usually when we're in some
sort of transition zone where we see
volatility creeping and there's news out.
And, you know, this news can be anything.
It changes all the time.
So these amber situations can really be
anything that disturbs the status quo in
the market.
And they can be negative and positive
surprises.
But what you'll find is usually they are
negative surprises.
So, for example, if we go back to the
volatility index, you know, the last
spikes that we saw in volatility, this one
here was the ratings downgrade of the
United States in the summer of 2011.
Previous to that, we had the Fukushima
disaster in Japan, which actually occurred
over a weekend.
And traders didn't really have the
opportunity to transition.
Prior to that, we had the flash crash in
May 2010.
And that happened very quickly as well.
So as portfolio managers, you have to be
quite careful.
You know, here in 2011, we had two
situations where volatility spiked.
And one of these moves in 2011, the Japan
earthquake happened at a weekend and
volatility just moved on Monday.
There was very little opportunity for
traders to transition at all, which is why
you saw so much volume when people were
de-risking.
At the lows of the market.
However, the ratings downgrade of the
United States, this jump volatility jumped
in stages.
And there was a lot of opportunity to
actually day trade around this level here.
And there were wholesale opportunities to
day trade.
So a lot of day traders made really good
money in this move.
And also in 2012, this move here, 2012,
this really came from Europe.
So we saw the moves in Spanish and Italian
bond yields, where there was a significant
increase in sovereign debt risk in the
Eurozone.
And we saw volatility jump from low to mid
teens up to the 25 level.
And we saw a sell off in the market ahead
of Mario Draghi telling the world that the
ECB would backstop the Eurozone.
And that was really the last opportunity
where you could have day traded on this
move where there were wholesale
opportunities and then build back into
your portfolio as volatility was coming
down.
And then basically for the second half of
2012 up to present day, volatility has
been very, very low.
So we've been able to be a portfolio
manager really for the last nine months.
So we're just in April at the moment,
April 2013, as we're making this video.
So for the last nine or so months, if
you've been day trading, you've been
killed.
If you've been a portfolio manager, you've
done really well.
Well, you've probably done really well.
So these amber situations, they can be
anything at any time.
So you just have to recognize what's going
on and do something about it if you're not
comfortable with the risk.
And there is no rule book, unfortunately.
But I guess the back of the envelope rule
is do something if you can.
Because you want to be able to free up
cash and free up margin in your trading
account so you can actually take advantage
of the volatility.
If you don't, then you're just the rabbit
in the headlights.
And you're the guy who's sitting there
twiddling their thumbs, wondering what's
going on, wondering whether you should do
anything.
And just watching your risk go up and up
and up.
And in the end, you may capitulate and end
up trading out of your portfolio at a
level where you shouldn't trade out of it.
And you might end up being the last person
to trade out, which is exactly what we
don't want.
So unfortunately, there is no rule book.
But I guess the first step would be to
actually recognize what's going on and do
something.
So back of the envelope, when index vol is
in transition and rising, then you should
probably look to trade out of half of your
portfolio.
So reduce the amount of positions in your
portfolio by 50%.
And then take a day trading approach and
just look for these opportunities for
directional bets over a one to five day
time horizon instead of one to three
months.
And then you do the reverse when
volatility is in transition and falling.
You should probably be looking at
increasing the amount of positions in your
portfolio by double, so by 100%.
And then take the portfolio based
approach, put cash to work in a well
diversified long short portfolio.
So again, there's no hard and fast rules
telling you exactly what you can and can't
do when the VIX goes up or down
aggressively.
Everyone's risk tolerance is different.
Everyone's strategies are different.
And everyone's portfolio looks different
and is made up differently.
So when the VIX does rally aggressively,
you've got to interpret what's happening
in the world at the time and why it's
going up so fast.
And then if you don't like the volatility
risk, then just reduce your portfolio,
reduce your exposure because you need to
understand again that as the VIX is going
up, the world's portfolio risk is going up
and so is yours.
And it's going up and there's nothing you
can do about it unless you actually go and
reduce your exposure.
And then when the opposite occurs, so when
the VIX is falling aggressively, you've
got to interpret what's happening and why
it's falling so fast.
It'll be falling fast because something
will have occurred that takes away the
risk in the market.
And you're going to be told by when you're
day trading, if you are at that time, that
this is happening because you're going to
find it increasingly tougher to make money
as a day trader.
And that's when you should be taking this
as a message and building a well
diversified long short portfolio.
And if you don't take this approach, then
all you're doing is you're not maximizing
your opportunities and you're not taking
the professional trading approach.
So if you're just a day trader all the
time, you're trying to dictate to the
market what you can and can't do.
Whereas professional traders actually do
the opposite and just let the market tell
them what they can and can't do.
And this is the classic retail trader
mistake.
So all of this stuff you've seen at the
beginning of the video series, but this is
why we're going through it again.
Because if you're seriously going to
consider day trading, then you need to
understand this stuff.
You need to understand why retail traders
typically lose money so much and so many
of them do that.
And this is exactly why, because they try
to tell the market what their
opportunities are and just take a very one
dimensional approach.
Whereas the professional traders take the
approach that the market allows them to
take.
Now, when you actually decide to day
trade, there is further reasons why the
vast majority of day traders lose money.
And we've already seen the first one, a
general appreciation for the opportunities
available.
So no appreciation for those general
opportunities that are available.
So people don't really focus on market
conditions.
The second thing is a lack of preparation.
So there's no similar to portfolio
management.
There's never really systematic processes
in place to determine what to do, given
the market conditions and asset specific
conditions.
The third thing really is unrealistic
expectations.
So most of the time, volatility in the
general market is too low to warrant a
100% day trading only approach.
This is the idea, again, that you're
dictating to the market what the
opportunities are.
And you're telling the market, this is how
I'm going to trade and the market's
irrelevant.
And the fourth thing is really just day
trading on old news or news that doesn't
really affect the asset that you think
it's going to affect.
And only using technical indicators.
So most retail traders that day trade
really just trade on newspaper articles,
TV headlines and old news, however it's
delivered to them.
And most because it's easy to understand
and it's easy for other people to make you
understand it.
Most people, most retail traders, when
they're day trading, just trade using
technical analysis systems that are just
not volatility dependent.
So you need to move away from this.
This idea that I can just follow a line on
a chart and just day trade because one,
the market doesn't allow you to do that
80% of the time.
And secondly, if life were that easy, we'd
all be doing it.
All professional traders would be using
technical analysis, day trading as the
only way to day trade.
The problem is, is that none of them do.
And, you know, the reason why people are
taught TA systems is because it's just
easy to understand.
And you're told what you want to hear,
retail traders are told what they want to
hear all the time, which is trading is
just easy.
And you can make an income from it and you
just have to follow this line on the
chart.
Unfortunately, it's not that easy.
As you've probably seen throughout the
video series, it's actually quite a bit of
work.
But once you're up to speed and you
understand how the market works and how
you have to approach the market in the
same way that professional traders do,
once you're up that curve, it's fairly
straightforward.
You just go through your processes, go
through the investment process that we've
seen, and have your processes in place
every week.
And the opportunities will actually
present themselves to you.
So that's the first thing, volatility.
We've just got to have a proper
appreciation of this and know when we can
and can't day trade.
And allow the market to tell us what the
opportunities are.
Second thing we're going to look at is
discipline and track record.
And we saw the Kelly criterion in previous
videos.
So we're not going to labor this point too
much.
But what you need to be doing is
absolutely having a separate Kelly
criterion for your day trading versus your
portfolio management.
If you mix them up, so if you mix your day
trades in with your longer term, your
medium to longer term portfolio positions,
you're not really learning anything in
terms of your self-awareness as a trader.
Because it's going to be really difficult
to tell whether you're good at portfolio
management and bad at day trading,
or bad at portfolio management and good at
day trading, if you mix all of your trades
up.
So you need to keep a separate Kelly
criterion for your portfolio management
and for your day trading.
So in the future, when you look back, you
can really decide what you're good at and
where you should be pulling from box A or
pulling from box B,
i.e. concentrating your efforts more and
deploying more capital to each area or to
either one of the areas.
So if you're a good portfolio manager and
a bad day trader, then you should be
pulling from box A in your life as a
trader and doing more portfolio
management.
In portfolio management, pull from box A,
deploy more capital and pull from box B in
day trading.
If you're bad at day trading and good at
portfolio management, you need to deploy
less capital or no capital at all when day
trading opportunities occur.
It just means you're bad at day trading.
So your P and L, your losses will tell you
that anyway.
But your case score will also tell you
that. But just make sure you keep a
separate Kelly criterion for your
portfolio management and your day trading.
Now, when you actually go in day trade,
we're going to look at how you interpret
news flow.
So economic and asset specific news flow.
And regardless really of whether you're
taking a portfolio management approach or
a day trading approach,
volatility and opportunities are generally
driven within two areas across the asset
classes, either as economic news flow or
asset specific news flow.
And economic, really, economic news flow
occurs at a macro level and affects
countries, currencies, commodities, bonds,
stocks and sectors relative to each other
within the stock market.
Because when you look at stocks and
sectors, we're looking at cyclicals and
defensives. So big moves in economic
expectations or economic news flow that's
significant really affects everything at a
macro level.
And at a macro level affecting countries,
we're looking at currencies and bonds, so
interest rates. And at a global level,
we're looking at commodities.
And also at a global level, we're looking
at stocks and sectors, so cyclicals versus
defensives.
In the asset specific news flow arena, it
really occurs at a microeconomic sector
level and unique level, i.e. a unique
level, meaning unique to the asset that
you're trading.
So currencies, so currencies really are
just macroeconomic and political only news
flow.
Commodities, news flow is pretty much
macroeconomic, but also demand and supply
dependent on micro factors.
So there are micro factors that affect the
supply chain and demand to commodities.
And bonds and rates are just macro and
political only.
And stocks, macroeconomic and stocks,
macroeconomic use flow affects indices and
micro affects sectors and unique specific
situations.
So companies themselves.
Now, if we run through the economics, in
the US, we've been through a lot of these
leading indicators, coincidence and
lagging.
You can classify them either as
coincidence or lagging.
But let's just run through them again.
So we've got the ISM Manufacturing Index,
non-manufacturing, UMCSI, building
permits.
We've also got the money supply and the
yield curve itself of the US bond market.
So you'll see a lot of the time that the
bond market will actually price in
slightly before the equities market moves
that are expected.
So a change in expectations.
And coincident indicators are really
lagging indicators to leading indicators.
So they provide us with confirmation.
So again, we've got inflation.
So producer price index and consumer price
index.
We've got the employment situation report,
non-farm payrolls, jobless claims,
industrial production, durable goods, even
FOMC meetings.
So the minutes of the meetings from the
FOMC.
And personal income, factory ordered
numbers.
These are all coincidence indicators.
And you shouldn't really be day trading on
these numbers.
Because the numbers are really known by
most professional traders before they come
out.
And all you're doing is providing
liquidity on the other side for
professional traders to trade.
And lagging indicators absolutely do not
trade on lagging indicators unless there's
a huge material change versus what's
already totally priced into the market.
So gross domestic product itself, the
unemployment rate, the Fed's beige book,
and retail sales.
You know, these coincidence and lagging
indicators are numbers that retail traders
who take the day trading approach, and
that's pretty much all of them.
These coincidences and lagging indicators
suck day traders in to trading on
headlines that just don't matter.
What really matters is where the market's
going to be in the future, not where it is
now or where it's been.
So leading, we're looking at what's going
on in the future and making decisions on
what we expect in the future.
Coincidence indicators tell us what's
going on in the market now, and leading
indicators should have told us this six to
12 months previously.
Unless there's any huge material
surprises, as a retail trader, you should
not be day trading on coincidence
indicator news flow.
So that leaves lagging indicators, which
means they're just almost completely
useless, unless there's a huge change from
expectation.
And there very, very, very rarely is.
So be careful in your approach there.
You know, imagine if you're the person
listening to this video now that day
trades on coincident indicators when they
come out and you day trade all the time.
Well, that just means you're day trading
in markets where the volatility index is
telling you that the opportunities to day
trade are extremely low and extremely
difficult to make money out of.
And you're trading on old news.
You're trading on what professional
traders classify as confirmation
indicators.
Unfortunately, that's what a very large
percentage of retail traders do.
And that's pretty much the reason, in a
nutshell, why most of them lose money.
You've got to do the opposite to that.
Only day trade when the market allows you
to do so.
And if you're going to day trade on
economic numbers, day trade on the leading
indicators.
What about in Europe?
Same thing applies.
Leading indicators, the ESI, so the
European Economic Sentiment Indicator,
where we have the Industrial Confidence
Indicator, which is the equivalent of the
ISM Manufacturing Index in Europe.
The Services Confidence Indicator, which
is the equivalent of the Non Manufacturing
Index, but in Europe.
We've got the European Consumer Sentiment
Indicator.
And then we've got Retail Trade Confidence
Indicator and the Construction Confidence
Indicator.
If you want to go into more detail, then
just go back to the video on the ESI, go
through it again, go online, go to the
website, download the data, and see how
the indicators are actually made up.
It's very straightforward to become a
student of PMIs.
All the information is publicly available.
You just go online and get it.
Coincident, in Europe, most popular ones
that retail traders day trade on, usually
industrial production, monthly inflation
numbers across all countries,
and the ECB meetings, ECB decisions, Bank
of England meetings, Bank of England
decisions.
They're usually lagging all the leading
indicators.
So six or 12 months before, the leading
indicators will have told you that the ECB
needs to lower interest rates, or the ECB
needs to increase money printing, or the
same for the Bank of England.
So by the time they actually do it, it's
usually priced into the market.
And lagging indicators, same ones, lagging
indicators are the same usually across all
regions.
So GDP itself, unemployment across all
countries, and retail sales across all
countries.
In China, I'm just going to introduce you
to a new one here, which is called the
Conference Board Leading Economic Index.
So that gives us now three that we can
potentially trade on, even as short-term
traders.
So we've got the HSBC, China PMI.
We've got the official People's Bank of
China Purchasing Managers Index.
So that's the Chinese government version.
And we've got the Conference Board Leading
Economic Index.
So these are the three main ones.
And you may even want to look at Chinese
export orders.
Export orders really are a coincidence
indicator.
They kind of fall between leading and
coincidence.
So you can make a decision on export
orders whether to day trade stocks
globally that actually have a lot of China
exposure in their earnings mix or in their
revenue mix.
And you may decide to trade commodities on
the back of that as well.
You can trade oil, copper, you can trade
the food commodities.
Coincidence indicators in China, exactly
the same.
Chinese industrial production and monthly
inflation numbers.
And monthly inflation numbers in China, if
you trade on those, there's something
wrong with you.
Because not only is it a coincidence
indicator, but the numbers are probably
just made up anyway.
And lagging indicators, gross domestic
product, unemployment, retail sales, the
same as every other geographical region.
So I've put together a table for you of
economic indicators that when they come
out, you decide whether you trade on them
or not based on leading coincidence or
lagging.
And what you're probably going to see is
an indication of what will happen in the
market when these numbers come out, if
they're indicated up or down.
So when you go through this table here
where it's got, for example, ISM
manufacturing indicated up, then you're
probably going to see stocks go up,
commodities go up, bonds go down, and the
dollar go down.
And then we've got the release dates in
here.
And then just assume that the opposite
will happen if you see ISM manufacturing
going down.
And then we've done this for every
economic indicator here that matters as a
leading indicator or as a coincidence
indicator.
If you see, for example, PPI indicated up
and you see stocks go up, commodities go
up, bonds go down, dollar sideways.
If you see that happen, then
non-participation is probably the option
because we're not trading or day trading,
short-term trading on coincidence
indicators or even lagging indicators.
So just make sure you've got your
definitions right of leading, coincident
and lagging.
And make sure you go through this table,
be a very useful resource for you when
you're doing any trading whatsoever, but
mostly in short-term trading because
you'll be able to work out what the
reaction is likely to be and whether
you're going to participate or not based
on the definition of leading, coincident
and lagging indicators.
Now let's move on to asset-specific news
flow.
And this is probably where you get the
larger opportunities to trade as a
short-term day trader.
And if you're trading asset-specific news
flow and you also have macro news flow
that's material, these create the bigger
opportunities because you've got wholesale
opportunities to day trade.
So for example, the VIX rallying 50% and
you've got materially positive or negative
news flow at a micro level, so sector
level and unique level at the same time as
that, then you're going to see big
volatility in those particular assets.
And that's where you should be deploying
capital if you've given yourself the
opportunity to do so.
So currencies, you won't get
asset-specific opportunities really there
because it's all macroeconomic news flow
and political only.
So when you trade a specific currency,
it's because a macroeconomic condition has
occurred which affects that specific
country.
In commodities, it's broadly macro, but if
you get micro news flow that specifically
affects that particular commodity where it
affects the supply chain, you're going to
have opportunities to day trade it.
And examples of this would be, for
example, the Energy Information
Administration in the US when they release
the inventories data for oil on a
Wednesday.
And you get big moves versus expectations
in inventory builds.
And that is basically affecting the supply
chain, but not necessarily at a macro
level.
There's been interference in the market.
That's unexpected.
And you can day trade oil on the back of
those situations.
Other good examples of this would be, for
example, in the food commodity space.
So in the grains like corn, wheat, in
pulses like soybean, in livestock like
cattle and hogs.
If you get microeconomic factors affecting
the supply chain in those commodities, you
can make good money day trading.
You'll see a lot of volatility around.
So, you know, good examples of this were
in 2012 in the food commodities, where
there was a heat wave in the United
States, and we had some of the lowest
corn, wheat and soybean crops for a
generation.
And the weather really affected the supply
chain.
And a lot of people made really good money
jumping into corn very quickly and day
trading it from the long side, and wheat
and in soybean as well.
And, in fact, if you'd have just run those
positions over the summer, you'd have made
a lot of money in those three instruments,
in those three commodities, because the
trend actually continued for a good few
months.
In bonds and rates, we've only got
macroeconomic and political news that
really affects the bond market and rates
in a particular geographical region or
country.
Micro factors really affect stocks the
most, where you've got situations that
affect particular supply chains.
So a good example of where the VIX went up
significantly and at the same time you had
micro factors affecting the value chain in
a particular industry.
And unique news that was affecting that
industry and stocks within the industry.
A very good example of that was the
earthquake in Japan in 2011.
Because with the earthquake in the
northeast of Japan, what you got was the
tech supply chain effectively being wiped
out in Japan.
And technology companies had to move all
of their supply chain to Thailand.
A lot of companies had to do that.
And then you also had the Thai floods
later in the year.
So there were some big day trading
opportunities or short term opportunities
in the US tech sector and the tech sector
as a whole globally.
So if you get all of those three things
lined up, that's where the big
opportunities occur in short term trading.
And that was a really good example of
that.
And usually you get these opportunities at
least once a year.
So you've got to keep an eye out for them.
Now what about connecting the dots and how
we hunt for volatility?
Well, when we get to asset specific news
flow, there's really five areas that we
need to consider.
We need to consider the results of
companies.
So earnings announcements and profit
warnings.
So when companies materially miss their
expected earnings numbers by the market or
they meet them and they warn on future
earnings.
So the market now has to downgrade their
expectations.
Bid rumors.
So where there's rumors around that a
company is going to be bought by another
company.
Unique events that no one could foresee
like a CEO dying in a car crash.
No one can ever see that coming.
And sentiment.
So big shifts in sentiment.
And big shifts in sentiment we mean by the
market now views an asset totally
differently because some unexpected news
has occurred.
Knowing your asset.
So this is pretty important stuff.
We're going to use some examples here.
We're going to use some examples from the
United Kingdom.
And we're going to go through a variance
of ATR.
So a variance of average true range.
So this is what you should really do to
understand if you're about to day trade
something.
If you're about to go into the market and
take a position on a day trade or a short
term trade.
This is the exercise that you should
really be doing once you've decided, OK,
I'm going to day trade this asset now.
And a lot of people go in unprepared.
So I would say the first thing that you've
got to do is make sure you read over this
quickly again.
Make sure you read over the day trading
best practices guide.
This will give you a good focus on whether
you should actually be taking a position
or not.
And how you outline your plan to do so.
Then move on to this.
Once you've actually decided, I'm going to
take a position now.
Then you should be moving on to looking at
a variance of the ATR.
So we're looking at here, Barclays in the
FTSE 100 from the 1st of April 2011 to
March 2012.
So we're looking at just about a year of
data.
And we're looking at an average share
value over the period.
We're looking at the average range, high
to low.
So this is the ATR.
We're looking at the average open to high
because we're assuming now that the market
hasn't opened.
And we're looking at taking a position
almost when the moment the market opens.
And the average open to low move.
And then we're looking at the average
daily move close to close on a one day
basis over this period.
And you should work this stuff out just so
you can, one, manage your expectations,
but also set stop losses and targets
correctly.
So first thing we're going to look at is
the Barclays volatility open to high.
So this is a variance of the ATR.
So we're only looking at the upside here.
And here we're looking at the downside.
So where the stock opens relative to where
its trading high is on a day going back
over a year.
And you can see very, very rarely does
Barclays have a day where it goes over
from open to trading high over 10p or 10p
in the UK.
And if you're going into the market in the
morning and you see materially positive
news and you think it's going to be a
really significant opportunity for day
trading.
Well, your opportunity to actually buy
Barclays from where it opens, you need to
be clearly buying the stock from where it
opens within at least 4p from where it
opens.
And have a stop loss and a realistic
target because very rarely does this stock
actually go up above a 10p difference from
the price that it opens.
So manage your expectations, firstly.
Secondly, set stop losses and targets
accordingly.
And we can see here the average open to
high move is actually just 5p.
So imagine if you don't get in at the open
and there's materially positive news out
and you don't get in and then from the
open you get in at 10p above the opening
price.
Well, the risk reward there just doesn't
exist based on historical volatility,
based on the open to high.
So you might want to make the statement
that, am I really going to get
opportunities here or am I just kidding
myself?
Am I doing a bum trade?
Should I be deploying capital to this
situation?
It's obviously up to you as the
individual, but you need to do these
things in common sense.
There is no rule book.
Remember when we looked at capital
deployment for spread trades and we said
there is no rule book that you can buy
which says this is how you deploy capital
in all situations.
There isn't.
So you just have to look at the odds here
and make a decision and use common sense.
So with an average open to high move of
5.1 pence from the open, if you buy this
stock above 5 pence from the open, your
odds of making money are actually very,
very thin.
So manage your expectations and make sure
that A, you either don't do it or B, if
you're going to trade in Barclays and you
get the situation at a good price and the
risk reward is there to set a sensible
stop loss and sensible target, then you
can actually go ahead and deploy capital.
So what about on the downside?
Well, it's pretty obvious there that on
the downside, there aren't much
opportunities to day trade Barclays.
You might want to move on.
You might want to look at something else.
The average open to low move is 4.9 pence.
If there's materially negative news out in
Barclays and you think you're going to go
into the market and short it on the open
and make 50p, there's something wrong with
you.
You've obviously not done your homework.
You've not pulled up the historical
volatility.
You need to check this and manage your
expectations, get in at a price that makes
sense and set stop losses and targets
accordingly.
And we've got some repeated analysis here
for stocks in the FTSE 100 and for the
FTSE 100 itself.
So you can go through those in your own
time.
But that ATR exercise, very, very
important.
Make sure you do that.
Make sure you do that before you ever put
on a day trade.
It's a variance of the ATR, but usually
within day trading, you're going to be
deciding before the open which way you're
going to be going.
You're either going to be going long or
short and you'll know it before the open.
Make sure you pull up the variance of the
ATR so the open to high and the open to
low data for historical volatility.
And manage your expectations.
Know your limit of where you're going to
get in.
Know your risk reward.
Set your stop losses and targets
accordingly.
If you don't do that, then you're just
what we call in the UK punting around.
You're just going to end up paying the
market money and losing money yourself.
It's that would be a very, very amateur
way of trading.
Okay, so let's just run through a quick
recap.
In terms of volatility, the importance of
volatility really can't be stressed
enough.
I'm not going to labor the point again too
much here, but make sure you watch this
video series over again.
You'll realize throughout this video
series why we mention volatility so much.
It's simply because as a trader, it means
everything.
Over any given time horizon, volatility
creates opportunities.
And if you have no volatility, you have no
opportunities.
Just apply that general rule to every time
horizon you look at.
And this is the first thing that retail
traders tend not to get.
And professional traders get from day one.
Because that's what professional traders
are taught from day one.
And we're taught how to actually spot this
and manage our expectations and manage our
approach accordingly.
Whereas retail traders just attempt to
dictate to the market what their approach
is going to be.
And that's why they all screw up.
And that's why retail traders, the vast
majority, lose money.
Because there is no appreciation for the
general opportunities.
The second reason is due to the lack of
preparation.
The third reason is down to unrealistic
expectations.
And the fourth reason is really trading on
old news and only using technical
indicators to trade on.
Or trading on news that just doesn't
matter.
It's not the important stuff in the
market.
As in what you're doing is you're getting
sucked in to trading the current market or
the past market.
And you're just providing professional
traders with the liquidity to get out of
situations that have already occurred.
Which they predicted at some point in the
past and are now actually news.
And then you're reacting to it and
providing us with the opportunity to get
out.
You want to actually be doing the opposite
of that.
And join the club, if you like, of
professional traders whose job it is to
predict the future.
So, as a quick recap, just know the
importance of volatility.
Understand it and monitor it. Watch the
video series as many times as you can.
Secondly, discipline and track record when
day trading.
Record every trade you do and do it in a
separate Kelly Criterion spreadsheet to
your portfolio management Kelly Criterion
spreadsheet.
Classify your news flow, whether it's
economic or asset specific.
If it's economic, ask yourself, should you
be participating in a coincident or
lagging economic news flow moment?
If it's asset specific, is the news
already known?
Is it old news? Is it new news?
If it's new news and you expect the market
to move, then you've got to hunt for the
volatility and find the assets that the
news will affect.
And you'll get the obvious one straight
away.
And you'll have to hunt a bit further down
the value chain to find the assets that it
might affect secondarily or secondary.
Most of the time, the obvious one will
move almost immediately and some of the
most or a lot of the opportunity will be
gone within a few hours.
So maybe you might want to focus on assets
further down the value chain where the
move, the big move will come later on when
everybody wakes up and realizes that it's
going to affect this asset as well.
And, you know, there's no rule book here
because we're looking across different
asset classes and we're looking across, in
stocks, different sectors and different
stocks.
So unfortunately, I can't give you a rule
book on how you hunt for the volatility
because the news that affects volatility
is different across all sectors.
And you're just going to have to do your
homework over time.
Over time, you're going to get to know
cyclical and defensive sectors anyway.
So you're just going to have to build up
your knowledge.
And lastly, knowing your asset, when
you've actually decided what you want to
go and trade and where you think the
volatility is going to be,
you've always got to know the historical
volatility and play the odds, get the risk
reward up with the open to high and the
open to low ATR.
Make sure you know what your expectations
or the expected maximum move.
Know where you're going to get into the
trade at a maximum on the long or the
short side.
Know the risk reward setup before you
actually go into the trade and set stop
losses and targets accordingly.
So according to the ATR and the
volatility, if the news is actually going
to be material, the volatility will be
bigger,
which means you're going to then be
surprised on the upside in terms of your
expectation and your expected profit or
loss.
So again, the day trading best practices
guide is attached in the download section.
So go into the download section, get
yourself in there, download it, read it a
couple of times at least.
And in the future, when you're going to
day trade or you think you're going to day
trade, let's say 30 minutes before the
market opens
and you've got your risk reward setup,
your entry, your plan ready to actually go
and day trade an asset.
Just have a read of that again, 30 minutes
before.
It's probably going to save you and make
you a lot of money over your life.
So just keep it as a resource in a folder
somewhere on your computer.
OK, so what we're going to do now is just
go over to the desk and have a quick
rundown and summary of day trading.
OK, welcome back.
So what you saw there was really the
approach to day trading that professional
traders really take.
And this goes right back to the beginning
of the video series.
And this is probably the most important
thing you should be taking away from this
section on day trading.
The most important thing really is
recognizing when you should and shouldn't
really be day trading.
And, you know, we're not saying here that
day trading is a bad thing.
All we're doing is allowing ourselves to
be told by the market when there's a lot
of day trading opportunities around
and when there are few day trading
opportunities around.
So when the volatility index is low, so
it's let's say below 25 or below the 20%
level and it's showing no signs of going
up.
What we're saying here is that really
there's very few day trading opportunities
around.
That's not to say that you shouldn't day
trade.
There will be opportunities around, but
they will be more difficult to find.
And also when you go and trade them,
they're going to be more difficult to
trade and make money from
because the volatility will be lower than
you probably expect.
So what this is all about really is
realizing that 80% of the time two things
are going to happen.
There's going to be day trading
opportunities around, but they're going to
be more difficult to find and more
difficult to trade.
And in the 20% of times where day trading
opportunities occur.
So let's say, for example, the volatility
index jumps 25 or 50% from the level that
it is.
There, then you're going to see a lot of
day trading opportunities.
You're going to be spoiled for choice.
You're going to have wholesale
opportunities to make money on a one day
basis.
So this is really about effective time
management and effective risk management
where 80% of the time you're realizing
that they're going to be more difficult to
find and they're going to be more
difficult to trade.
And when volatility jumps in that 20% of
times where there's wholesale
opportunities, you're going to get more
volatility and more assets.
Therefore, day trading opportunities are
easier to find and also they're easier to
make money from.
So that's the first thing being able to
recognize that in those 80% of times in
terms of time management, you should
really be focusing on the portfolio
management aspect of trading.
And then in the 20% of times trying to
transition to become the short term
trader, the day trader who makes money on
a short term basis.
And then when the that's when the green
lights on for volatility, when the red
lights on transitioning back from being a
short term trader to a portfolio manager
and taking a one to three month time
horizon approach and building out
portfolios.
Again, we go back to this point.
Unfortunately, there are no hard and fast
rules. All I can show you really is best
practice guides and you're going to have
to call yourself the situation of when you
transition and when you transition back.
So that's the main point. That's the main
thing that you have to recognize here. Now
when you actually do go and day trade,
what you've actually got to do is a few
things. You've got to recognize and hunt
for the volatility in situations that are
going to create day trading opportunities.
When the volatility index is low or high,
what you're probably going to find is that
the best day trading opportunities are
ones in which there is a unique situation
occurring, as in it's unique and specific
to the asset that you're going into.
Because volatility is created on short
term basis in two stark situations.
Firstly, which we've already seen, when
there's a big picture occurrence in the
markets and there's lots of volatility in
the market, the VIX has rallied and the
green light goes on and it creates many
opportunities.
The second thing is, regardless of where
volatility is, something unique happens to
an asset. It's only specific to that
asset. They're the two things where
volatility is really created.
So that's where you're going to find the
opportunities in all situations, but
you're going to find lots of opportunities
to day trade when volatility is high.
Now when you actually go and trade, day
trade on a short term basis, you've really
got to go through the processes of pulling
up the ATR and setting your stop losses
and targets within that ATR range.
So your expectations are managed. Don't
forget, now that volatility has increased,
the ATR is going to go bigger.
So even when you're setting your stop
losses and targets within that ATR range,
you're basically managing your risk more
effectively in a more volatile market,
which is the approach that you have to be
taking.
That's just to stop yourself from being
human exactly the same ways as we looked
at in portfolio management.
Also with the Caddy Criterion, you should
absolutely be keeping a separate Caddy
Criterion to your portfolio management
Caddy Criterion.
This is really so you understand as a
trader what you're good at and what you're
bad at.
So you need to be really focusing on
making sure your Caddy Criterion for day
trading is separate to your portfolio
management Caddy Criterion so you get that
appreciation.
If you're a bad day trader and you learn
this over a 6-12 month period and you just
lose money and your case score is bad, you
should not be deploying capital to
yourself as a day trader.
You've learnt and been told that you're
bad at it, so why would you then take more
risk?
You need to be not giving yourself money
and pulling from box B in this situation.
If you're good at it, then pull from box
A.
When the green light comes on, deploy
capital to the situations that you believe
will make you money over a short term
basis, as in when volatility is high.
Or there's a unique situation occurring.
So make sure you keep the Caddy Criterion
separate.
At least you're going to know over a time
period whether you're good or bad at
portfolio management and good or bad at
day trading.
If you put all the trades together in one
Caddy Criterion spreadsheet, you're not
going to learn anything.
It's going to be very difficult to know
what type of trader you are, what you're
good at, what you're bad at.
So make sure you do that.
So that's pretty much day trading in a
nutshell.
Now let's move on to the next video.
Let's move on to video number 27.
We're going to now create a trading plan
with all the stuff that we've learnt up to
this point.
Creating a trading plan is fairly
straightforward given the knowledge that
we've got.
We've just got to take the first step to
basically approaching trading correctly
and getting all these processes in place.
So we know each week what tasks we have to
complete.
Generating ideas, gatekeeping, risk
management on live portfolio and
transitioning from being a portfolio
manager to a day trader.
And managing your self-awareness
statistics.
So let's go over to the next video and
I'll see you on the other side.
Thank you.